Під час націоналізації "ПриватБанку" майже три роки тому
кожен український платник податків фактично власним коштом
профінансував порятунок найбільшої фінустанови у країні.
Повернення "ПриватБанку" колишнім власникам означало б
не лише втрату вже інвестованих коштів,
а й новий удар по гаманцях громадян. І ось чому.
Порятунок "ПриватБанку", клієнтами якого є понад 20 млн людей,
обійшовся держбюджету України в 155,4 млрд гривень.
Саме стільки коштів влили на докапіталізацію банку.
За нинішнім курсом це понад 6 млрд доларів.
Таким чином, за даними Нацбанку, кожен українець віддав зі своїх податкі
приблизно три з половиною тисячі гривень на порятунок "ПриватБанку".
Щоправда, докапіталізація відбувалася не напряму, а через випуск держоблігацій.
Ці облігації взяв на баланс Національний банк.
Звісно, свого часу можна було би замість порятунку ліквідувати банк.
Така доля вже спіткала інші проблемні банки в Україні.
На думку експертів, з одного боку це коштувало б менше  платникам податків.
Оскільки обсяг гарантованих державою депозитів становив у грудні 2016 року
близько 100 мільярдів гривень.
Втім, з іншого боку, за твердженням оглядачів,
ліквідація "ПриватБанку" уповільнила б зростання ВВП країни через різку зупинку платежів.
На банк припадає близько двох третин роздрібної платіжної інфраструктури,
банкоматів, карток. Саме завдяки безперервній роботі банку з проведення платежів
вдалося запобігти паніці, яка могла би призвести до масового зняття грошей.
Як поясню ють в НБУ, з юридичної точки зору
сценарій повернення "ПриватБанку" надзвичайно проблематичний.
Законодавством не передбачений механізм скасування рішення НБУ
про визнання банку неплатоспроможним.
Окрім того, в судовій практиці України та світу
відсутні прецеденти повернення націоналізованих активів ексакціонерам.
Ба більше, скасування націоналізації означало би
необхідність повернення "ПриватБанком" державі 155,4 мільярдів гривень докапіталізації.
Таких грошей у банку немає, а відтак це призведе до його банкрутства,
і зрештою постраждають клієнти фінустанови.
Водночас держава буде змушена надрукувати понад 100 мільярдів гривень,
щоб повернути їх вкладникам банку в межах програми
державного гарантування вкладів фізичних осіб.
Так принаймні вважає голова Нацбанку Яків Смолій.
Це, своєю чергою, негативно вплине на інфляцію і на курс національної валюти.
Тим часом судова тяганина та невизначеність щодо майбутнього банку
вже встигла затьмарити співпрацю Києва з закордонними фінансовими донорами -
перш за все, з МВФ, вважають оглядачі.
А будь-яке наступне судове рішення на користь ексвласника
може викликати паніку серед клієнтів "ПриватБанку" і підштовхнути їх
до масового вилучення грошей з депозитів,
якого вдалося уникнути кілька років тому.